mara gay who uh we mentioned last week
for some dumb things she said and i
can't even remember what it was but it
doesn't matter
she was on msnbc saying more dumb things
and uh
this time she had some thoughts on the
american flag now i i saw this
clip being posted on on twitter by
conservatives
and they were quoting her as saying that
that
she saw the american flag and it was
disturbing her and i actually i don't
know i'm still optimistic and i try to
see the best in people you know that
about me so i actually
before i clicked on the clip i thought
uh you know
are they did she really say that exactly
or she just sort of implying it
did she actually come out and say that
directly
um i even had a little bit of skepticism
but it turns out no that's exactly what
she said let's listen
the reality is here that uh we have a
large percentage of the american
population
i don't know how big it is but we have
tens of millions of trump voters
who continue to believe that
their rights as citizens are under
threat by simple virtue
of having to share the democracy with
others
i think as long as they see
americanness as the same as one
with whiteness this is going to continue
we have to figure out
how to get every american a place at the
table
in this democracy but how to separate
american-ness america from whiteness
until we can confront that and talk
about that
this is really going to continue i was
on long island this weekend
visiting a really dear friend and i was
really disturbed i saw
you know dozens and dozens of pickup
trucks with
uh you know uh explicatives against joe
biden
on the back of them trump flags
and some cases just dozens of american
flags
which you know is also just disturbing
because essentially the message was
clear it was
this is my country okay
so she saw pickup trucks with
with uh all you have to do is laugh at
that's all you can do is just laugh she
saw
pickup trucks and she was disturbed and
she saw american flags and she was
disturbed
just think about the bubble these people
live in
they they really do
you know that's not just some populist
cliche but these are
elitists who live in a bubble
and they go outside of that bubble and
they are horrified by normal things like
pickup trucks i'm just imagining mara
gay you know walking down the street
seeing a pickup truck
and crumpling down on the sidewalk in
tears
oh my god what is that thing what is
that
um and she was disturbed by the american
flag as well
she's very clear about that you know
it's it we think back to
colin kaepernick when he began his
protest
after he was benched and you know his
nfl career was falling apart and and
that's when he discovered his uh
his passion for social justice and
activism that total coincidence of
course but
and he started doing his whole thing we
were originally told that
that it was not a protest of the flag
it's not a protest of the anthem it's
all a protest of
of police brutality for years that's
what we were told
meanwhile many of us mostly on the right
we we from the very beginning pegged
this as
no he's protesting the flag that's what
he's doing
um this is not about police brutality
and for years and years the left told us
that's that's uh that's a libelous
charge it's not true
well now they're pretty open about it
they actually just hate the flag itself
and they hate what it represents
they hate the fact that when someone's
flying the flag they're saying this is
my country
well yeah mara that is what they're
saying and it is their country
[Music]
okay if you're an american it's your
country they're americans they're flying
the american flag
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content